it's the communist party who've led the
anti-vaxx charge in russia
and here they are campaigning against
mandatory vaccination
not keen on masks either it seems
[Music]
it's only some public sector jobs in
certain regions where it's mandatory to
take the vaccine
but that includes teachers like tanya
shirokova
i'm not a communist but i think it's
very important to me that
vaccinations should be actually must be
not obligatory not mandatory would you
take it anyway though
no why not i've got some troubles with
my immune system
and i think that this vaccination just
ruins it and
it's no way for me and for my children
russia's third wave is in full swing
delta driven with as many deaths in
moscow in a day
as the uk is seeing in a week
vaccine take up is picking up but slowly
the strange and tragic thing is that
having pushed their sputnik vaccine so
hard abroad it
is only really now that the kremlin is
trying to get people back home
to take it and with the delta variant
pushing the death rate to new
peaks each day that is clearly far too
late for literally
hundreds of people
only now is this kind of footage getting
play on russian newscasts
exhausted doctors and patients fighting
for their lives
not at all the victory that russia's
president declared over covet this time
last year
and he still can't resist vaccine point
scoring
astrazeneca
three times and she's never got a jab
the last time she was in intensive care
and on a ventilator
what would you say to other russians who
aren't sure about taking the vaccine
business
[Music]
this week moscow's bars and restaurants
introduce new restrictions
only people who've had the vaccine a
recent case of covert or a recent pcr
can come inside
no qr code no entry and for expats right
now they're hard to get
they're the first real measures since
moscow's only lockdown more than a year
ago
the country has been to a degree for the
normal person being moving as normal for
a long time so people don't feel that
it's
a way out of the situation that we're
collectively in life is normal so why
should i take the vaccine
after decades of state-driven propaganda
many russians are happier to trust what
the rumor mill tells them about the
virus and how to beat it
than anything their government says
with the variant outstripping the
vaccine that may come
at quite a cost donna mcnair sky news
moscow